[Music]  we have seen far more than baby steps  five years ago the eu battery industry  was hardly on the map  today europe is a global battery hotspot  with 127 billion euros in investment and  some 111 industrial projects emerging  across our member states and we keep  moving forward  [Music]  to see europe among the global leaders  in e-mobility an essential part of the  green and digital economy  we are well on track to produce enough  batteries for 11 million cars a year by  2030. if we can maintain this momentum  i'm sure we will achieve strategic  autonomy in the battery sector  [Music]  first it's high time to adopt the  proposed batteries regulation setting  high sustainability requirements for  batteries placed onto the eu market  second we all have to put our bags into  securing battery raw materials and third  i want to see our european battery  academy expanding across more member  states to prepare our workforce for this  fast growing sector so stay tuned  you